I asked Johan about it I was like did
you go to the ATM and take money out of
my account he's like no I was like are
you sure today there was someone went to
the ATM and took money out and he's like
no straight up lied Johan completely
breaks Danielle's trust by taking money
out of her account and then lying about
it so I'm like okay so I have to go to
the bank and ask them for a video of who
took money out of my account and then
finally he's like yeah fine and just
like bangs his people and was super
angry did he not think she was smart
enough to find out where was his mind
did he even think this through and it
gets
worse the fact that you is asking for
reimbursement for rent doesn't make any
sense to me man I wish I could ask my
apartment building for my rent money
back when I'm ready to go what let's get
into
it
hey 90day fans fam it's melissia all
right at the top of the episode Danielle
explains how she found out Johan has
been sneaking off with her card
yesterday I was sitting in the kitchen
and I open up my bank account and I
found these this like one charge it was
$40 so I go through my account and I see
that this has happened multiple times
and I didn't recognize them and they
were ATM withdrawals and I was like I
didn't go to the bank and I asked Johan
about it I was like did you go to the
ATM and take money out of my account
he's like no Johan finally admitted to
it but only after Danielle said she's
going to ask the bank for video so now
I'm like what the and he was just like
not responding not engaging with me and
being like a about it like not even
apologetic she says she went and locked
herself in her room now she's trying to
figure out what's next so so now I'm
like do I say absolutely not pack up my
go back to New York or do I try to work
with him to figure out why he's behaving
in this way girl
no I'm sorry I get wanting to make your
marriage work but my first reaction is
pack your stuff and go home unless you
want to continue to raise what feels
like a teenager K Michelle said it
best
check a different
[Music]
check real cuz you can't raise a
man he's already grown what you going to
do that song is so real Johan has to
want to do the work at this point but
for now he's avoiding
responsibility
you lied which suggests you were trying
to be sneaky if you really do believe
you are entitled to that money as her
husband why didn't you say yes I took
the money out of the account it was me
probably because he knew he had no
business doing
it
[Music]
look he can't even sit with what he just
said think about it only a thief would
lie if if you were innocent why would
you lie you didn't do anything wrong I
would do anything to make my marriage
work fast forward in comes Danielle who
confronts Johan about his lack of
honesty
did you choose an equal though
Danielle let's be real yes we are all
equal as human beings but as far as a
partner she picked someone who on paper
in character and in maturity seems to
not be an equal partner to her and
that's no shade to Johan he's on his own
timing and journey but but in my
unsolicited
opinion you have to pick an equal
partner you can't hope or try to turn
someone into that they did get married
after 5 months of knowing each other
though maybe she thought some of the
characteristics she desires would come
out later
on
why is he setting himself up like this
as Danielle calls out the transactions
on her phone Johan tells her that she
was the one going to the bank and making
withdrawals isn't that gaslighting
trying to make someone question their
own
sanity in total Johan made four
withdrawals of a total of
$160 but this has nothing to do with the
amount of money that he took out I
wouldn't even mind him taking money out
of the bank if he needed it the problem
is that I asked him if he took it and he
said no that's where I'm really
scared Johan goes on to tell Danielle he
took the money out for food and she hits
him with her go-to like are you kidding
me you didn't because you had no food in
the house there's a freezer full of meat
and 20 lbs of rice at all times this
moment right here is giving Mom going
off on her teenage son who thinks he's
grown out here taking money out of her
account and getting tattoos by the way I
had no idea Danielle had Johan's name
tatted on her like that wow no wonder he
thinks he can do whatever Johan proceeds
to tell Danielle that if he would have
asked for the money she wouldn't have
given it to him he then calls her
selfish I invested way more money than
you in this
relationship every single thing you have
came from me dang I know his ego felt
that that's disgusting to even
say Yan you're getting lazy with the
lies now you just said you took money
out of her account to buy
food like are you kidding me Danielle
basically tells Johan since you want to
act like that next month we are
splitting everything in the house
5050 and if not you need to go home to
your mama okay
no Johan then goes on to say something
ridiculous this isn't a home you're
investing in you're renting the place
you paid for your time
there the fact that Yan is asking for
reimbursement for rent doesn't make any
sense to me like why do I owe it to him
has he lost his mind like I'm not paying
you
okay the answer is hell no this season
Johan has made it clear he wants to be
treated like a
king but you just don't become a king
because of your genitalia a real king
acts like a king he has King energy he
moves with Integrity he keeps his word
he's honest I mean the list goes on not
saying Johan has to be perfect but if
you want to be treated like a king be
king like or at least try that isn't the
way it's going to work
enough and I'll admit I'm not sure if
Danielle provides the best environment
for him to step into that all right back
to this week's episode you know damn
well that you have not paid for even a
quarter of the things that I've paid for
here you don't want to pay for anything
and anytime I ask you to pay for
something you get angry it was different
when you were in your mother's house and
you were broke it's not that way anymore
you have
resources you need to use them or you
need to find another American Wife one
who is codependent there are so many I
can refer you out yeah I don't know what
Johan has seen when it comes to American
women saving men in the Dr but clearly
he picked the wrong one Danielle already
shattered his dream of going to the US
by not applying for a spous of Visa he
was also expecting for Danielle to buy
them a house of their own and a car I
make sound financial decisions at this
stage in my life and buying a car with
$30,000 that I don't have is not an
example of a sound financial decision
you think it's a sound financial
decision because it's not your money
sometimes I wonder if Johan requests all
these things from Danielle as a form of
payback for deciding without him that
they're going to live in the Dominican
Republic which is something that I
wouldn't be surprised if she did in
large part due to the fear that he could
be using her for a green
card Johan's calling it a horror story
and Danielle says she's in a nightmare
the last 24 hours have been a nightmare
well wake up leave which is actually
what Danielle is about to tell Johan to
do don't go
home I'm not giving you
money
you are such a piece of wow does he
really take Danielle for a fool you are
such a piece
of get the out of my house get out of my
house you are out of your mind and I
don't want you here anymore do you
understand that I don't want you
here I never thought that Johan would
would be the kind of person that
wouldn't want to contribute equally I
believed that he didn't contribute
because he
couldn't but now that he can contribute
and he's choosing not to and actively
choosing to steal from me who's provided
for him for all this time like this is
so unreasonable it's insulting it's
embarrassing and this is more evidence
that Johan is only with me for money if
Yan's intentions for marrying Danielle
were not pure
he needs to sit in the Dr and accept the
consequences you can't use people and
play with their heart and expect for it
not to bite you in the butt eventually
and speaking of intentions Danielle
might have married Johan mainly for his
looks and his
package might have I don't know either
way this also proves that those two
things things can only take you so far
she is sitting in the house with a quote
unquote fine man miserable all right
next week Brandon's mom is in the
Philippines for his wedding to Mary and
she is not holding back you come from a
dysfunctional environment wait I can't
wait to get context around that
statement because Brandon does too I can
tell that she's still judging me we are
trying to be better as a couple as much
as I know that you guys love each other
it's not
enough we'll see all right 90day fan
spam make sure you stick with ET because
we are covering it all I will see you
next
time